Just before we get
started with video today,
you've clicked on this one,
you already knows about a place rather
than a pass and we're trying something
new.
We're experimenting.
Why not?
This is super interesting.
I promise.
It's like a biography of Chernobyl,
the place and what happened there.
I really think you'll enjoy
it and let's get into it.
I exactly.
One 23:00 AM on April the 26,
1986.
The weld suffered its worst ever.
Nuclear disaster outside of the
town of preppers in Ukraine,
reacting them before the local nuclear
power plants quite literally blew its
top.
It released more nuclear material into
the atmosphere than the Hiroshima and
Nagasaki explosions combined.
The resulting cloud of death blanketed
half of Europe led to the total
evacuation of parts of north Ukraine
and southern Bela reuss and triggered a
process that would end up five years
later with the complete collapse of the
Soviet Union.
When we talk about disasters,
there are certainly a scale
of disasters in this one.
It rang someone near the top,
but how much do most of us really know
about history's worst nuclear accidents?
If you go on wikipedia right now,
it will tell you the total number
of deaths due to drug noble is a 31.
The overall impression that you get is
that it's a disaster that's noticeable,
but not really on the same league
as something like nine slash 11,
but impressions,
they can be misleading for
those living in the USSR,
Chernobyl,
it was there 9:11.
It affected workers from each
republic in the Soviet Union.
It permanently damaged trust in the
government and it left behind a deadly
legacy that still being
reckons with to this very day.
In the biographics video today,
we're looking at the story of a town,
the blue up at embark.
It was a chilly February day in 1970
when the first brick of the new city was
laid some 90 kilometers north of Kiev.
Privets was officially under
construction as the ninth of the Ussr,
so called atomic towns.
Places built solely for the families
of those people working at the nuclear
plants.
In this case that demands the Vladimir
Lenin blondes just three kilometers
north.
The plants,
you know today,
it's true noble life in bread,
but it was fun.
I'll be on the standards common
in the Soviet Union at that time.
The automatic towns with Moscow,
his pride and joy,
those who lived in them could
expect fully stocked shops,
hospitals with actual equipment since
apartments that were the envy of people
from Vilnius to have a lot of all stock.
Even by these high standards
out there was something else.
Former residents still talk of.
Local forests replete with natural
beauty and wax lyrical about visiting the
river.
Beach runs on sweltering summer days,
but from the get go it was a darker side
to this new city over at the nuclear
plants or 40 is were quietly installing.
Rbmk reaction is famous back then for
that ability to be converted to nuclear
weapon production at the drop of a hat.
This useful ability also made them
incredibly unstable like driving a car
without breaks in only a short time.
The reactor to prep it was going
to go screaming over a cliff edge,
taking his passengers right along with it.
On the eve of the disaster though,
everything seems to be going well,
just fine.
Officially given city status in 1979,
prep has grown into a booming metropolis,
a 43,000 people with an
average age of only 26.
The young population meant no
shortage of weddings and celebrations,
and the town had become a hugely desirable
posting for Soviet scientists over
the Vladimir Lenin nuclear ponds for as
well already up and running with a fifth
one on the way form of private residence
later cooled those last days a kind of
paradise.
If that was the case,
it was about to be one
that was lost forever.
One of the greatest ironies of the should
enable disaster is that it was caused
by of all things safety test.
On the night of April the 25th,
19,
86 engineers,
untrained in nuclear physics,
decided to find out if the newly
built react to number four good.
Still operated some emergency water
pumps in case of a power failure,
so they disconnected it
from all the fail safes,
removed the control rods and
shut off the main power source.
There was always a edge that almost
immediately ran out of control in a panic.
The engineers tried to reinstate all 200
control rods back into the reactor at
once.
This turned out to be a really bad idea.
The control Rod said graphite tips that
facilitated the unstable reactions that
were already taking place no sooner
were they in the reactive and it was hit
with the mother of all explosions.
The 1,200 ton cover,
it was blasted into the APP.
Radioactive debris shot a kilometer
into the night sky to workers in that
control room.
We'll just killed immediately.
Incredibly.
This survivors of the plans had no
idea that just triggered a bonafide
catastrophe there.
Geiger counters what good up to detect,
low amounts of radiation exposure,
the sort of thing you might normally
expect from working at a nuclear plant.
When the reactive spewed forth some of
the highest radiation levels ever seen,
the geiger counters just stopped
working back in prep apps.
The local fire brigade
mobilized nearly 30 minutes,
screamed up to the reactor in their
trucks with no protective clothing on and
pour water onto the fire.
That was raging,
but the flames,
they wouldn't go out and not only that,
the men complains of a metallic taste
on their tongues and the feeling of pins
and needles in that faces
by the time they got home.
At the end of that shifts,
a number of these first responders were
already showing signs of acute radiation
sickness,
yet still no emergency was declared.
When news reached Moscow
at 5:00 AM Soviet leader,
Gorbachev was infamously told
that the reaction was so safe,
it could be placed in
the middle of Red Square,
had Gorbachev taken them up on that
offer would have been a heck of a site.
The ruins of reactor number four,
where at this point buried under 14 tons
of highly rubble and burning it 3000
degrees.
It was also spewing radiation over
north Ukraine and southern better reuse,
plenty of which was already
finding its way to Pripyat.
Is it been a hot night that night and
prevents many slept with that window's
open,
unaware the cancer causing particles
when are blowing into their bedrooms and
saturating on they're exhausted bodies.
Yet when we woke up,
it wasn't too warranted.
Mass panic to an ordinary day.
Yes,
most of these people were nuclear plants
workers and most new something has
happened,
but no one knew the full
extent of the disaster.
As radiation fell and
invisible deadly clouds.
Children played outside in the streets.
Mothers went shopping and
men got ready for work.
The one discordant note was the sudden
appearance of mosque soldiers on the city
streets.
They stood in twos or threes,
monitoring the crowds and
not answering questions.
It was the first sign the residents of
prep outside of the nuclear tsunami that
was about to engulf them
all by the evening of April
26 radiation levels in prep
out west 600,000 times the normal,
the excellent documentary,
the basket which neighbor,
which by the way is one of the
main sources for the section,
estimated that anyone exposed to those
levels would have received a lethal dose
interest for days.
Clearly the Soviet authorities
were going to have to react fast.
A tpm on April the 27th
with the deadly fire,
still burning three kilometers away,
a thousand school buses were driven
into prep and parked on every street
residence were gone outside and told they
had two hours to pack their belongings
and prepared to be evacuated.
There's been an accident.
They said,
don't worry,
you'll be away for three days
and we'll sort this all out,
and then you can come right back.
I mean,
come on with the Soviet authorities,
we lie to you so that's residents
prepared to leave their paradise.
They packed quickly,
taking only what they could carry.
Then all 43,000 when loaded onto the
buses and driven away in the vast flat
emptiness of northern Ukraine.
None of these people would
ever see that homes again.
So now you might be wondering,
well,
what was going on in Moscow while
this nuclear apocalypse was unfolding?
Well,
the answer is nothing.
at least not much.
The credit then did put a scientific
delegation together to study the problem,
but aside from that,
Soviet authorities basically sat on
my hands like a kid who's faster,
just a party and tried not to let
the rest of the big countries see him
blushing.
Unfortunately,
the radioactive fought,
or at least by Chernobyl,
was just like a regular fat
in one important respect,
it stank and also in the
eggs and then kind of way,
but the stench of radiation
which is capable of being
picked up by even the most
basic of equipment.
On April the 28th Swedish scientists
monitoring their own nuclear plants caught
the first whiff of that silence and very,
very deadly emission with only what
we can imagine was a figurative.
They all turns do the
other countries and said,
hey guys,
guess what the US is lodges did.
Now will they?
Moscow would try the
geopolitical equivalence of
whoever smells at Delta for the
next 24 hours.
The jig and it was up on April the 29th.
The Kremlin came clean.
From this point on,
I became a global emergency.
It was around this point that the
first responders arrived in Moscow,
is hospital number six,
the one place in the whole of the Soviet
Union get up to treat acute radiation,
sickness of the he also farm,
and he would responded that night,
28 would die in agony,
fair skin bund from that boons by an
invisible enemy in the aftermath of the
first responders,
deaths and additional a hundred 30,000
people were evacuated from the towns and
villages surrounding prep apps.
Yet even now,
these Soviet authorities response
remains woefully lacks in Kiev.
A mayday parade was held with the
blessing of the Communist Party despite a
change in wind direction,
meaning radioactive dust was now fooling
on the Ukrainian capital like a deadly
reign one week off to the initial blast,
the meltdown.
It was still going on.
The fire itself had
been put out with sends,
but the reacts to it continued to burn.
Meanwhile,
dangerous readings were coming in from
his phone away is Greece and France.
It was against this worrying backdrop
that the International Atomic Energy
Agency made is most worrying announcement
default with the reactor melting
downwards through the Pons trenoble.
It was on the brink of a full
blown nuclear explosion time,
real quick explainer,
the water,
the first now dead firemen
had dumped into the reactor,
had pooled at the bottom with
a top of the destroyed reactor,
now plugged with sand to contain the fire.
Any molten radioactive goo that
reached the water could trigger a chain
reaction,
which in turn could trigger
a nuclear explosion,
and we're talking about something
in the range of three megatons yeah,
that's 200 times the size of the bomb
that fattened Hiroshima according to the
utterly terrifying online tool,
new comap.
Depending on the way the wind was blowing,
this could have doubts,
not just Minsk,
but also Vilnius,
all the way in Lithuania with catastrophic
levels of radiation where the wind's
blowing toward us.
Kiev,
95 kilometers to the south,
it could have turned the Ukrainian
capital into a silent tuner.
It was at this point that the liquidators
arrived in the last years of the USSR.
The liquidators were the equivalent
of nine slash 11 first responders,
the men and women who were marched into
the jaws of death determined to do that
duty.
They comprised army reservists,
firemen,
nurses,
police officers,
miners and pilots,
plus the scientists and
workers who accompanied them.
They came from every single
one of the Soviet republics,
from Estonia to Georgia,
from Kazakhstan to as Pakistan old,
old,
half a million of them
converged on Chernobyl during
the dark days of mid 1986.
Very few of them escaped on Scott.
To read this story is to read a
tale of heroism and suffering,
not seen since the siege of Stalin Grad.
There are the 600 pilots who
flew over the burning reactive,
dropping lead on it to
plug the broken top.
Latest suffered myriad health problems.
There are 125 five and sent beneath the
meltdowns and drain the water out and
stop the second explosion,
most of whom got sick and then there are
the 10,000 miners who came from Russia
to create a concrete chamber beneath
the reactor to stop it poisoning the
groundwater.
Two thousand 500 of which would die before
the age of 40 that were then ordered
to clear radioactive debris from the
roof of the power plants were radiation
levels were so high they
have to work in 40 seconds.
Shifts or risk receiving a fatal dose.
Miners were forced to dig in 24 hours
shifts without any protective clothing.
Then there are all the stories of the
cleanup decontamination at the sign
itself.
The countryside surrounding
Pripyat was so contaminated.
Entire forest tent to be bulldozed,
buried villages were
scrubbed from tip to toe,
perhaps most shockingly special squads
were given guns and sent out into the
countryside to shoot all
the dogs and cats less.
They're radioactive now prove
a danger to humans all told.
It was one of the biggest clean
operations in human history,
rivaling even deepwater horizon.
It lasted six months,
whereupon a 30 mile exclusion zone was
established around prep apps and it
remains there to this very day.
The final capstone was the sarcophagus.
This was a concrete Bam off.
It was placed over the reactor
at the very end of 1986,
just as the first snows began to fall.
It seals reacts number four off from the
outside world completely ensuring that
it would remain safe at least for
a time you see the sarcophagus.
It was built in a hurry and there
was designed to only last 30 years.
This wasn't seen as a problem is
when 2016 finally rolled around.
The Soviet authorities would clearly
still be in charge and Ukraine and that'd
be able to replace it with another one.
I mean,
it's not like the entire
Ussr always gonna compete.
You collapsed in the
next half decade or so,
right
on November the ninth,
19,
89.
The world watched in horror as ordinary
Germans toppled great chunks of the
Berlin Wall.
Well,
God swatched on it was the start of
the complete collapse of communism in
Eastern Europe and the final
dissolution of the USSR in Ukraine,
mass protests against Moscow
didn't break out until 1991,
but when they did,
they did so under trend nobles,
deadly cloud in Kiev,
protesters were photographed in gas masks.
And protective clothing waving signs
referencing the disaster at a political
level.
The shutting out of Ukrainians from a
disaster in their own backyard had immense
consequences,
the most immediate of which was key ever
declaring independence on August 24th
that year,
but the fallout from Chernobyl
had effects fall beyond Ukraine.
The Economist has argued that the huge
economic hits the USSR took from the
disaster directly lead to its collapse,
but on the fringes of the
Chernobyl exclusion zone,
former residents of prep had watched
these events with undoubtedly mixed
feelings while their homes had been lost,
the authorities that built them a
new city to recreate that paradise.
Many of them still worked at
the old power powerplan's.
Remarkably,
the three other reactors had been
restarted by the end of 1986.
Apparently,
danger be damned yet new cities
can't make up for the toll.
Trenoble took on its
liquidators across the USSR.
Hospitals had spent the last five years
flooded with those who worked in the
zone today.
It's estimated that around a third of
the surviving liquidators are disabled in
some way in Bela Reuss,
which got more radiation than Ukraine.
One study estimated that as many as 20
percent of the adolescent population
suffered birth defects
related to the accident,
as for the number of excess
cancer deaths Chernobyl caused,
we simply don't know the World Health
Organization estimated on the 20th
anniversary that it was around 4,000,
but estimates vary wildly.
One of you report,
but the number closer to $60,000,
whatever the truth,
the aftermath of Chernobyl has been a
source of anger in Ukraine and better
batteries ever since when the plants,
other reactors were finally shut down
and following international pressure in
2001 few lamented that passing the
drama when it wasn't over in the late 19
nineties,
it became clear that Ukraine was never
going to be capable of rebuilding the
sarcophagus.
When it finally failed,
it was at this point that it became
abundantly clear that the sarcophagus was
never going to make us until 2016,
despite being built to last 30 years.
The Soviet sarcophagus was
already on the brink of collapse.
The next 10 years alone were spent
shoring up the old structure to prevent
another catastrophe.
Then in the mid two thousands and new
song called Fergus had to be built that
would completely contained the old
one at a staggering 35,000 tons.
The new sarcophagus,
it was a miracle of engineering,
builds 300 meters away from react to
number four to limit radiation exposure.
It took 10 years to assemble.
It then had to be rolled over the old
sarcophagus and completely sealed.
It was taller than the statue of liberty
and bigger than an Olympic stadium when
it was finally sealed in November of 2016,
and it cost one point $5,000,000,000.
This one though,
it's expected to last the next one,
hundred years.
During that time,
robots inside.
We'll deconstruct the old sarcophagus
before finally dismantling and making the
reactor itself safe.
When the new sarcophagus
finally reaches his end in 2116,
it's hoped humanity,
we need to build an even bigger one today.
The glistening new structure,
it looks over a landscape that's
very different from the one reacted.
Number four,
changed forever.
In 1986,
the x paradise of prep that is no longer
just empty this crumbling away beneath
and on sort of nature,
the ones team forest,
so now so devoid of people that the
exclusion zone has become an accidental
wildlife reserve.
Teaming with wolves,
bears,
beavers,
and links,
not the people that have
completely vanished though
just a few short years ago,
the Ukrainian government agreed to let a
small number of Chernobyl evacuees back
in around $200.
Now,
if within the zone itself,
dicing with death on a daily basis,
you can even go to visit them tonight.
We'll receives tens of thousands of
tourists a year drawn by the allure of
Ukraine's,
very own pompei and I actually went to
did this last year and it's well worth
doing as for the disaster itself.
Well,
thankfully it remains the worst
nuclear accidents on record that as the
Fukushima meltdown in 2011 was,
it didn't even come
close to 1986 eruption.
Hopefully neither accident
will ever be exceeded.
Now,
normally this is the point where we
wrap up a biography and say a few pithy
things and just that those credits roll,
but Chernobyl story when
it's still far from Ovid,
it's estimated that the zone will remain
uninhabitable for humans for another
24,000 years,
a stretch of time that's
almost beyond comprehension.
It was only four and a half thousand
years ago that the pyramids were first
built in Egypt.
Try to imagine for a moment just
how different life was back then,
how impossible it would have been for
your average slave to close his eyes and
imagine our orwell's to
imagine spaceflight penicillin,
the outs now,
multiply that feeling by a factor of six.
You'd have some idea of the scale of
time left until Chernobyl's affects.
Stop being felt.
I'll story today.
It might be over,
but the tale of Chernobyl is
only just getting started,
so I hope you found this video interesting
and there's a little bit different to
our normal stuff,
but we thought we'd try a biography
of a place just for a change of pace.
I found this one personally super
interesting and if you did like it,
please do give us a thumbs up below.
Let us know in the comments what you think
of doing this sort of video every now
and again would love to
hear from you and as always,
thank you for watching.